this video is brought to you by software
keep get your Microsoft products at a
discounted price Apple only gave the
base 15-inch MacBook Air 8 gigs of RAM
and 256 gigs of SSD and even worse when
we opened it up we confirmed that yes it
only has one SSD chip meaning the
storage is really slow so what happens
if you spend extra money an upgrade to
512 gigs of storage or if you go up to
16 gigs of RAM well in this video we'll
show you the real world differences and
that will give you guys real
recommendations on who should spend the
extra money instead of just some
theoretical stuff now you might think
who cares I'll just wait a little bit
longer for my transfers but that's not
going to be the whole truth first let's
run our standard SSD speed test dang
guys look at that difference right there
now the base one is going to speed up a
little bit on a second run and we ended
up settling at
1538 right compared to 3000 390 over
double and as far as their read speed it
is almost double if you spend the extra
200 bucks going up to the 512. now here
it seems like we have double the speed
but let's go ahead and plug in our
external SSD and now I'm going to
transfer our PC test folder over here as
you see it's 117 gigabytes and we
started transferring at 1.3 gigabytes
the fastest the sac could do and now
it's slowed down to about 260 because
most ssds after he wrote enough they
slow down dramatically it's almost done
here and Pam that just got done I cannot
believe this that's probably the longest
it's ever taken five minutes and 40
seconds and guess how long the 512 model
took
57 seconds yes more than five times as
fast not just that twice as fast
difference we saw before now if you're
thinking I don't care about transfer
speeds I'm not going to do a big
transfer as well this is going to affect
your real world performance as well but
before I get into that if you like
working on documents spreadsheets or
slideshows our sponsor software keep is
giving our viewers 25 off genuine
Microsoft software like Microsoft Office
for Mac they're fully legit since
they're a Microsoft certified partner
with over 100
000 five-star reviews and great customer
service with 24 7 365 customer support
so buy Microsoft Office for Mac or any
of their other software today and say 25
off they're already low prices by using
link below and the coupon code mtac-25
now I don't want to scare everybody off
and be unreasonable if you do buy a base
model it will still be very quick if you
use a specific weight so here I have
figma online web design software and
this project is brought to you by 500
designs one of the best studios in
California and here as you guys could
see I'm zooming in there's a couple
glitches but stuff is loading very very
quickly let's come in here and on the 16
gig model let's zoom in right here
ma'am took a second to load the
performance is the same and then
selecting and exporting 12 of these high
resolution layers both machines take the
same a minute and 48 seconds to do so
and running our web browsing performance
test the performance is almost identical
so if you're just running one or two
basic things at a time the base model is
perfect for you but most people are
going to open up a bunch of tabs uh
they're gonna have different
applications they're not closing and
that's when you start getting into some
stuff now before I open up a few things
I'm going to run this Baseline export as
our last test without having anything
else opened up and in Lightroom here or
other applications that use both CPU and
GPU we could even see a difference with
nothing else opened and that's because
even the 16 gig model is using over two
gigs of swap our base 15 inch air is
using over four gigs of swap but overall
it's using less Ram because the MacBook
itself and Mac OS is limiting how much
RAM Lightroom can have access to which
is going to slow it down now if you
don't know what swap is basically if you
don't have enough RAM it will use your
SSD in order to act like Ram so the
computer doesn't crash like they did a
long time ago but it can keep working
and that is where that slow SSD that I
showed you in the beginning really
starts to come in our 1300 MacBook took
2 minutes and 20 seconds compared to 1
minute and 17 seconds on the upgraded
model so there you're spending a little
bit more money it doesn't seem like as
good of a value as 1300 bucks now but
the performance is almost twice as good
and this is just with Lightroom open and
now what I'm going to do is open up 10
web browsing tabs here I have my Google
Drive I'm going to have YouTube opened
up here maybe with the video that I'm
listening to in the background I'll have
a few different website lights opened up
that have a decent amount of media and
then some simpler ones and I have two of
my email accounts opened up like I
typically do and as you guys can see I'm
using Safari not Chrome which actually
uses more memory so that's a tip if you
have the base MacBook use Safari so
right here I have 10 tabs open a lot of
you guys say 10 I never have 10 I have
30 I have more but I want to keep it
simpler for those of you guys that might
not push it as hard just know your
results will be worse so as far as
opening up things right now
you guys see right here it took a little
bit of time to load up and that's just
with web browsing tabs I have my emails
I want to open those
Google drive both of them were quick so
far not bad but let's go ahead and open
up Lightroom classic bam both of them
loaded it up just fine now I'm going to
switch between these images here
let's go back into Safari
there you guys saw it took about three
seconds or so and then it had to kind of
load it up whereas this one was still
instant not just with one program open
and here in my Google Drive the 16 gig
model super responsive still let's try
the base one
you guys see that it's already choppier
slowing down so the system is getting
worse in terms of performance
see super smooth that one was laggy and
that is just with 10 tabs in Safari now
the next I want to do is re-export this
and let's see how long it takes this
time wow guys we are already at 8.8 8.9
wow guys look at this this MacBook is
almost finished compared to that one
right there all right guys so this time
around the 16 gig model only took a
second longer one minute and 18 seconds
compared to 3 minutes and 32 seconds for
the base one so this thing dramatically
slowed down and now the difference is
getting closer to Triple but with that
said I'm never just sitting around
waiting for something to export keep in
mind there's only 50 images it would
take much longer so if you had for
example 200 300 400 this thing would
take ages I would be using the system so
I'm gonna go ahead and run that one more
time and let's check out the
responsiveness is if you're multitasking
like most people will
so let's go over here let's open up
Safari
all of that right there you guys saw all
the stuttering
let's go into our Tesla here pretty
smooth that it's open once it's opened
up reloading there
relearning there but not too bad
this page is open up just fine
YouTube right there bam the whole video
had to load back up not crazy so
surprisingly but keep in mind this is
Safari Chrome would be much worse and by
the time I open up Google Drive it's
reloading again now the stuttering
is really quite bad oh my goodness
this is making it be
very frustrating let's check out our 16
gig I have to run this again because
it's so fast at doing this test all
right let's open it up
not perfectly smooth
but look at this
everything's open none of this changed
none of the video went away
extremely smooth here
let's check Google Drive
bam instant super smooth while it's
exporting
wow guys
a lot of that is just dramatically
slowing down and while we're
multitasking I ran the speedometer test
here and you guys could see that the
base model instead of being the same web
browsing performance well now it is
almost half the speed that it was
previously and that's all affected by
that slow Swap and the lower amount of
RAM and if we take a look well right now
we're at six gigs of swap I saw it was
almost at 10 gigs earlier but it's
probably trying to lower the ram that
Lightroom needs if I open this up we are
still exporting that is incredible here
I've done already like four times bam
and right here we have seven minutes and
16 seconds compared to a minute and 18
that is if you have the web browsing
tabs open and you're multitasking while
your export is happening that affects
the base model whereas the other one
well it is basically unchanged so should
you spend that extra 200 bucks or 400
and if you can only do one which one
should you get well in previous videos I
showed you guys more tests some video
editing tests some photoshop tests
um some logic stuff like that the videos
were very long but in this one I just
want to sum it up because in video
editing you'll have a very similar
performance to the Lightroom over here
for xcode well it is not as RAM
dependent and it does a great job with
swap so if you're doing a little bit of
coding I wouldn't worry about it as much
and if you're doing logic well there if
you're doing very simple projects 16
gigs you don't absolutely have to have
it but if you start doing plugins and
you want to really Excel then you
definitely do need 16 gigs now what's
interesting is that Apple where their
configurations are set up they have a 8
gig 256 the slow SSD model and the 512
so they're basically admitting that hey
the base model it shouldn't be like that
if you're going to upgrade anything you
should upgrade your storage and I would
say that if you're somebody that wants
smooth multitasking smooth web browsing
you're not trying to get maximum
performance I would do that now if you
could do both as I showed you guys here
the experience is much better if you're
multitasking if you're doing
productivity heck this is just Safari in
one professional application if you do
Photoshop and Lightroom stuff can get
even slower so I would do both if you
can but if you cannot I would say it
would be worth just getting the better
SSD not only does it keep your eight
gigs running much faster longer you also
get double the storage so that would be
my recommendation to you guys and
hopefully this shows you guys how big of
a difference you can get just by
upgrading that and I would highly
recommend it but like I said in the
beginning for some people if you're just
doing Simple a few web browsing tabs
you're not doing too many stuff or you
just have one thing opened at a time you
could get away with it but the value is
not as good when you're talking about
bang for the buck performance go and
click that Circle above to subscribe
we're gonna have other comparisons and
other great videos for you guys check
out that video right over there and
software keep below and I'll see you in
the next one
foreign